lo hace la universidad de la Florida que
tiene un centro de estudio electoral y
dice que hasta el momento son cerca de
9,5 millones de estadounidenses que han
votado de forma anticipada casi siete
millones ha mandado su voto por correo y
casi aproximadamente dos millones y
medio de estadounidenses se ha acercado
a las urnas de forma anticipada a votar
en estas elecciones de medio término que
recordemos pues no solamente están en
juego 35 sillas al senado 435 sillas a
la cámara de representantes sino también
36 gobernaciones y 34 alcaldías en todo
el país además de cargos públicos
locales que también están en juego se
espera entonces a partir de esta
votación que la participación sea
récord de hecho en Estados como Georgia
ya se registra un millón de votos más en
comparación a las elecciones de medio en
el 2018 se espera que los afroamericanos
las mujeres y las personas los adultos
mayores las personas que tengan más de
50 años sean los que más acudan a las
urnas en estas elecciones Y es que
Obviamente el clima político en Estados
Unidos está bastante polarizado hay
temas por ejemplo como la seguridad
temas como la inflación y la economía y
temas como la migración que los
republicanos Pues están aprovechando
para impulsar este discurso que lleve a
que más simpatizante republicanos salgan
a votar por el lado de los demócratas se
están aferrando bastante al discurso de
El aborto para impulsar a muchas mujeres
a que salgan a votar y precisamente los
afroamericanos y las mujeres están
batiendo récords en cuanto a
participación en estas elecciones de
medio término